Es ist fast so hart wie diamant und bei extremer hitze
entstanden ein russisches forschungsteam hat jetzt ein völlig unbekanntes material gefunden das es so auf der erde nicht gut was er bisher über
dieses außerirdische mineralen namens ua kritik wissen dass er vater jetzt mal geht es im science fiction herzlich willkommen
Der besuch aus dem weltraum wurde benannt nach dem fundort des meteoriten das bisher unbekannte
material heißt ua geht und der methode indem es enthalten war wurde im jahr
2016 in der sogenannten uhr kit region in sibirien gefunden und er hat was mit auf der erde gebracht
was es hier so bisher nicht gab das darin entdeckte mineral kommt nur zu einem sehr kleinen anteil in den methoden vor und ist nur
unter dem mikroskop sichtbar tatsächlich sind die mineral stücke mit fünf mikrometern
kleiner als unsere blutkörperchen die 6 mikrometer großen konkret handelt es sich um einen treat das würfelförmige
kristalle bildet und aus vanadium
stickstoff und einem kleineren anteil aus chrom und eisen besteht spannen dabei ist das element hat ähnlichkeit mit
anderen kosmische mineral verbindungen die stickstoff beinhalten der mittel selbst besteht hauptsächlich aus
eisen genauer sagt aus kammern zieht und das zu 98 prozent dabei handelt es sich um eine eisen
nickellegierungen die mindestens 90 prozent eisen aufweist weiterhin konnte das russische
forschungsziel mehr als zwölf weitere minerale bestimmen die sich zum großteil eben nur in gestein
aus dem kosmos finden lässt sie entstehen erst bei deutlich über 1000 grad celsius
auf der erde findet man solch eine zusammensetzung eben nur im meteoriten die fachleute folgern daraus dass der ur
petit metroid bei sehr hohen temperaturen geformt oder mehr als 2000 grad celsius
diakité kristalle sind meist ungestört und lassen somit darauf schließen dass der stoff sehr früh aus der eisen nickel schmelze aus
kristallisierte und somit ein
eigenständiges material bild sie zukommt das von anderen betrieben einer ähnlichen
umsetzung keine spuren gefunden werden konnten doch weil sich nur so wenig von dem außerirdischen mineral in den meteoriten
befindet kann das neue element nicht in allen einzelheiten
analysiert werden dazu das forschungsteam
unglücklicherweise ist es uns aufgrund der sehr kleinen körnung nicht gelungen alle physikalischen und optischen eigenschaften
von ua kritik zu ermitteln dazu seien weitere funde mit einem höheren anteil des elements notwendig oder eben weitere
weiter entwickelte technologien so wissen wir bislang also nur einige dinge zur zusammensetzung und struktur des minerals mit
hundertprozentiger sicherheit das forschungsteam versucht aber andere physikalische eigenschaften des elements aus vergleichen mit
vanadium nitrit zu bekommen so folgern die fachleute dass das element sehr hart ist es erreicht auf der entsprechenden
härte skala einen wert von 9 bis 10 damit ist es eines der härtesten bekannten mineralien überhaupt und reicht sogar knapp an
diamanten der tatsächlich die zehn knackt das forschungsteam geht davon aus dass pakete
ausschließlich im weltall vorkommen kann und zwar in eisen nickel asto ihnen die bei hohen temperaturen
geschmolzen sind doch eine ausnahme gibt es wahrscheinlich und zwar den erdkern auch er besteht vermutlich aus eisen und nickel
ob sich ua christoph auch befindet das werden wir wahrscheinlich
nie erfahren und wenn ihr zu diesem und allen anderen themen kein video verpassen wollt dann habe ich am ende des videos noch einen
kleinen trick für euch jetzt aber unser hochgestecktes ziel keine werbung mehr auf gigs mehr schon angefangen immer mehr videos sind werbefrei
dank eurer hilfe tausend dank immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mich wieder gewonnen haben
schalten wir die werbung vor einem video ab werdet also mitglied hier unter dem video draufklicken
und ihr bekommt noch exklusive extra videos live streams und noch ein paar weitere privilegien
für einen kleinen beitrag und wenn er den link nicht findet
wir haben auch noch mal in der video beschreibung und jetzt der trick wenn ihr immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp nur da bekommt ihr das aktuelle video und deutlich vor allen anderen von mir persönlich auf euer handy
einfach hier draufklicken und da drunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken außerirdische
revolution bei der suche bis dann